all right we're back on David dr. rod
what can we expect the President to
accomplish in his last year's
well now almost months in office yes
well I think he's gonna move forward on
climate change
huge huge initiative I think that he's
gonna work on these issues that go to
middle-class security which is in his
view I think in most people's view the
biggest issue of our time how do you
build an economy in which people can
actually work and get ahead we need to
work on climate change the enough had a
snowball in his hand the other day yes
plainly that refutes all the science yes
he had a snowball in his hand and batter
I had I had a reporter say to me why is
he working on this it's at the bottom of
the NBC Wall Street Journal poll where I
got a young granddaughter I'm thinking
I'm gonna tell her from the grave at the
end of this century hey where I had
worked on this problem at the NBC Wall
Street Journal poll is right I mean
that's well said Matt what can you tell
us about the book you're working on
about Eric garner Eric garner the New
York man who was choked by the police
for selling loose cigarettes yeah no I
mean it's all the same issues we were
talking about before I mean the Eric
garner case was I think it really
exemplified everything that's wrong with
community policing in this country and
it's it's a fascinating story about race
and why people hate each other in this
country and and it's so I'm gonna spend
a year working on it okay Genevieve what
would a Republican health care bill look
like well I think there's a lot of
different options out there right now I
would encourage people to go to heritage
org where I work if you want to see a
whole host of plans but I think one of
the first things that we could do is
especially this court case goes away
that it could which means a lot of
people that currently have health care
that can no longer mobility the
subsidies are gonna need health care and
I think states need to be taking action
right now I'm not waiting for the
Supreme Court to come down to say look
we're gonna do two things we're gonna
make sure that these people are taken
care of they can either go back to plans
that they had before that they lost or
that we can create plans that basically
are not as expensive because we don't
have to have all the mandates that
Obamacare required which makes a lot of
plans expensive and third I think states
ought to compete not compete but people
who live in what say California wants to
mandate I don't know hair transplants
it's a part of health care let's just
say they do that's why in California
shot at Dave right if it's mandated but
let's say that somebody in Arizona says
look we're gonna have a plan it's much
more narrowly focused it just really
covers some very basic things the
Arizona plan is gonna be to people in
California already able to buy at the
health plan in Arizona people in Arizona
ought to be able to buy health plan in
Massachusetts they should have more
choice and I think if we're looking for
freedom and choice in health care and
giving people options that's a good way
to go Dave what do you say to that I say
xx we've cut the uninsured down by 25%
you say people can go back to their
plans these people didn't have plans
that's why they need health care they
had the emergency room that's a plan yes
but now what most of them have it I did
well we have eight point four million or
eight point five million folks signed up
in exchange they're like September of
last year about 7.5 million thing at
seven point four million those folks did
get private insurance throw Medicaid
it's a great deal if you have nothing
before isn't it you give somebody in
Medicaid court says oh now you have
health care if fewer and fewer doctors
are taking Medicaid which is a fair
answer and certainly in a lot of
grounded areas then yet you have a card
but you can't get into the doctor and
that's a good health care I agree it's a
mess this is why we should just have a
single-payer system like every other big
boy
well the murder of a prominent Russian
opposition leader this week spark any
international response against Putin
well first of all he's not terribly
prominent I lived in Russia for ten
years boris nemstov he was really you
know not terribly relevant in modern
Russian politics our Putin just didn't
like the gunman was seen leaving the
crime shirtless riding a bear they say
you know it no doubt in your mind it
well it's a hundred yards from the
Kremlin and you know who else is gonna
do it an organized hit you know on that
bridge right next to the Kremlin right
pretty odd there's not that many other
suspects and he's running the
investigations and you think it was just
because he could do it he wasn't even
really that much of a threat
well people here in the United States
they over do they overthink it and they
say well it really wasn't in his best
interest they should we just left him
alive the optics are bad of leaving him
alive they don't think about the optics
of this stuff they just doing like
weeding seems really concerned about
optics yeah yeah we tend to think like
everybody thinks like us and they don't
yeah but I mean Putin is a European
problem isn't it I mean I don't know
he's a bad actor also realized a there's
lots of them do we have to get me around
everywhere why can't people clean up
their own neighborhoods what Kant would
want many of the one well so what what
important is not sponsoring terrorism
over here I mean you can kind of make
the case against Isis that way that they
might sponsor terrorism here but Putin's
not doing that so what do we give a [ __ ]
about Crimea it's not our problem
you know the Russians definitely see the
NATO's encouragement into that partial
is it clearly in you know
an intrusion yeah that they feel that
they were promised during the 80s that
NATO would disintegrate when the Soviet
Union collapsed right they take that
stuff very seriously may they see it as
aggressive on our part not on Putin's
part okay
generally what do you make of the
challenges to Speaker Boehner from his
own party will there be a coup I think
the biggest challenge already occurred
when they read the run and that you know
I
he won overwhelmingly but I think people
forget that the fact that it 20-7 forgot
what the exact total was with the fact
that he had as many as he did vote
against him was it was a big statement
but look I think the the challenge for
Boehner is gonna be in Mitch McConnell
over the next two years I mean you have
a president who doesn't want to be in a
lame-duck president quite frankly and
why I don't like a lot of his policies
and grants lot of his politics I do
admire he's willing to put the pedal to
the metal and push as much of his agenda
through as he possibly can and I don't
agenda well I mean what his agenda is
it's always kind of countered to the Tea
Party agenda it seems like they there's
a pattern over and the president's
wanting to push his enjoy something
committed to his agenda and do whatever
it takes to get it through some of which
I think it's not constitutional at times
but nonetheless he's willing to push it
John Boehner and Mitch McConnell have
not shown at this point that they're
willing to do the same on their side and
so I think the next two years I think
Republicans better be concerned about
there being 2016 in getting being so
disgruntled with who's there that
they're just focusing on who's running
next while the president still being
president you know what I think is there
the dog that caught the car they wanted
to run the Congress now they're running
the Congress and the tail wagging the
dog right they don't know what to do
about it
okay all right thank you everybody thank
you or answer we'll see you all next
week